it was about 12 years ago that i first
heard of this machine
[Music]
it's a brain slicer
but not just any old brain slicer that
you'd find at home depot or your local
serial killer hobby shop
this
is the best brain slicer in the world
and it lives at harvard university
this machine may sound medieval
but it's at the heart of one of the
grand scientific and computing
challenges of our time
researchers here want to use it to help
them build a three-dimensional map of
the human brain
they want to photograph a brain slice by
slice
stitch all the pictures together into a
computer model
and then go find every neuron and every
synapse and the trillions of pathways
that connect them
scientists call this brain map the
connectome
and some of them are convinced it could
unlock the secrets of how the mind works
other people think this whole project is
a colossal waste of money and time
luckily for scientists and for you
i have come to harvard to settle this
matter once and for all to the connect
home
[Music]
whenever i'm at harvard thinking about
the origins of human consciousness and
the mechanics of life
i visit this man
i'm jeff lichtman i'm a professor in the
molecular and cellular biology
department at harvard university and a
member of a group called the center for
brain science
jeff is also one of the world's leading
connect home experts and runs a
laboratory
here this idea that there is a
connectome a wiring diagram that is
worth knowing it remains controversial
to this day to think about a map a
physical map of the brain's connections
very much the way people in genetics
thought of the genome
as a physical map of all the sequence
information for every gene
in a body
genomics
at its early stages there was also some
controversy over whether it was really a
good idea right it was also considered a
huge data set it was about
1.4 gigabytes of data 1.4 gigabytes and
people were thinking what are we going
to do with so much data but the idea
here is that the technologies now exist
to get wiring diagrams down to the level
of every single connection of every
single nerve cell to every other nerve
cell you're basically talking about
finding every neuron
every synapse all these connections
between them and so i mean we're talking
about on the order of trillion
you know trillions of wires oh yeah yeah
i mean it's almost inconceivable to get
a wiring diagram of the brain you need
enough resolution to see every single
synapse and that resolution is
lower than the resolution of light
microscopes it's controversial what's
the great pro case for why we want to do
this you see the united states has put
tons of money in trying to do a connect
home europe has put tons of money so
obviously there's a group of people that
believe this is a big deal why what what
is the big hope maybe the one that is
most generally interesting is that there
are a number of disorders of brains
where we still have a very poor idea of
what actually is wrong and a number of
people believe that
the reason these diseases are so
difficult is that they go to the
structure of the brain and we have
really no idea what those pathologies
are diseases that are not uncommon
autism spectrum disorder schizophrenia
tourette's syndrome
i don't think we're going to get very
far until we have some physical evidence
of what's wrong
memory in its true sense in the sense of
a neuroscience thinking about it or the
way a normal person thinks about what
they remember
where is that what is that what does it
look like how is it configured in the
brain it's almost certainly in the
wiring diagram but until we start
getting wiring diagrams we're not going
to have a good idea
a brain schematic sounds like an easy
enough thing to build
but in the decade plus that i've been
following connect home projects around
the globe
progress has proven tough to come by
researchers have managed to build models
of tiny worm brains and slightly larger
fly brains
the goal these days is to image an
entire mouse brain
and then one day far in the future a
human brain
it turns out that our brains are so
complex that they require an almost
unprecedented amount of computing to
analyze
you guys recently did a cerebral cortex
in a human but a cubic millimeter cubic
millimeter of that but that's how hard
this is right how long is it how long
have you that took uh several years
several years and two teams a big team
at google and a big team in my lab okay
working full-time yeah
the problem here is that the wires are
not ordered
they're not all running like train
tracks in the same direction they're
running in three-dimensional space more
the way spaghetti in a bowl
would run one way of generating a map of
every wire in every direction is to cut
that bowl of spaghetti piece of brain
into very thin slices take each of those
pictures then align them and then find a
piece of spaghetti and track it
through the volume and then start with
another piece of spaghetti and track it
through the volume and keep doing that
until you have all the spaghetti
these are 30 nanometer sections
typically which is about a thousandth
the thickness of a human hair okay each
section
the first step in building a connect
home is to get your hands on some brains
and then cut them up
it all sounds very grim but harvard
turns out to be quite efficient with its
brain harvesting
jeff's lab can do a year's worth of
research with a single mouse brain
small chunks of the brain are fed into
the slicer where a diamond blade carves
off a thin sliver of tissue
the tissue floats along some liquid and
onto a piece of tape
the brain slices are then put into this
very large machine where they're
photographed in the finest of detail
software helps stitch the pictures back
together into a single 3d image and
algorithms are applied to help make
sense of what's going on inside of the
brain
this summer lickman's lab along with
google announced their major
breakthrough on the human connect home
front they created a 1.4 petabyte visual
model from one cubic millimeter of human
cortex
within that tiny sample were millions of
neurons and 130 million synapses
all of these parts were then labeled by
an obedient and hardworking ai algorithm
whose brain sample is it was there
something
it's a woman who had
epilepsy and she had surgery she had
surgery and to remove the epileptic
focus the neurosurgeons made an incision
in the temporal lobe to get access to
the disease site so they could
extirpate or in some way remove
the part of the brain that was causing
the epilepsy
if we zoom up
every one of these objects
is now a uniquely identified
object
in the data there's hundreds of millions
of objects in here if i take
an object like this that has a sort of
triangular shape that looks like a
pyramidal neuron and i just double click
on it
there it is
i mean it almost looks like a cartoon
but that's the actual this is a real
cell and if i do that for this cell
there is it and if i do it for
this cell
i'm gonna have to unzoom a little bit to
give you a sense of this but you're
making the bowl of spaghetti and
everything in there is traceable
that's a place where a cell receives a
synapse
and then i'm going to zoom up on that
spot in the electron micrograph
here is an axon
making a synapse
on that dendritic spine and i can do
that for every one of these
let's look at this
so this is something i saw
with my own eyes
and then asked my colleagues if they'd
ever seen anything like this
and no one had so here is a axon that's
something that's talking
where the dendrites of the cell are in
red that's the cell that's listening
and this axon comes to this position on
the cell and makes something that looks
sort of like a turbine it's a
massive wiring
weirdness
if you follow this axon it keeps doing
this
here's the same axon
another whirl and that's the thing about
large data these things that are called
unicorns you know these weird things
that there's one of
when you have 1.4 petabytes of data you
can discover that they're rare but
they're not
one-offs do we have any
speculation about what
happens one person in my lab
richard chileck suggested that maybe
this is a magnetic coil
that the electricity travels here and it
generates a magnetic
charge i think that's a crazy idea
but
he took offense he said you got a better
idea
not everyone at harvard is a full-on
connect home believer
so for another view on the matter may i
please present to you
the bad boy of brain science florian
engert
this man knows how to make an entrance
ashley hello
good to see you
how are you i'm well
good lovely day it is a nice day huh
is that
how you usually cruise around that's how
i commute
sitting here slotted between two rhinos
i got right into it and asked this man
in a purple muscle t what he makes of
brain maps
there's controversies around the the
connectome to some degree of of some
people
you know there's there's people who
think it will be useful in different
ways so there's some debates there then
there's a camp of people who think this
is
maybe not a waste of time but it's not
going to lead yeah so where do you fall
is the connectome a worthwhile pursuit
well it's not going to be sufficient
maybe that's the most important
statement just having the connect home
by itself will tell you basically
nothing
i think it is
extremely useful
once you have a model a theory of how it
works the brain
and you want to use the connectome to
falsify or test or constrain your model
florian's lab specializes in researching
the brains of zebrafish
and he has a glorious collection of tens
of thousands of them
these fish turn out to be ideal for
brain research
just after they're born they have
translucent skin
this means that scientists can peer
directly into the animals minds and
watch their neurons
fire florian and his team of
over-educated fish farmers have altered
the genes of these animals so that their
neuronal activity really lights up under
a microscope
we have maybe a few thousand
different transgenic fish lines the
different populations of fish that we
need
to monitor and manipulate neural
activity in individual parts of the
brain and that's what you see here and
so like each case would maybe have a
different property or you need more than
one row so from here to here
they would all have expressed a
fluorescent indicator in a very specific
part of the brain and other fish would
express in different areas of the brain
or a different indicator who keeps track
of what happens i mean you just have
them all numbered and somebody said oh
you know we have a bar coding system
there's a whole database that needs to
get updated and we have a staff
of three people
and a head fish mistress okay who takes
care of the whole facility and she keeps
track of maintenance and housekeeping
but when you're looking at this brain
activity it's the first couple days of
their life it's day five till day eight
okay day five for day six or zebra fish
has a whole repertoire
of behaviors that they need to survive
that's what they do they interact with
corn specifics they hunt they escape
competitors and they navigate
florian was too important to explain how
the actual microscoping part of all this
works
and so poor postdoc gregor stepped in to
help
so i can get a fish in addition and
carry it into the microscope and then
kind of set up an experiment
first gregor embeds the fish in the
laboratory equivalent of jello then he
strips away bits of the jello to let the
zebrafish move its body and tail
the idea is to see how the brain works
in a living animal going about its
day-to-day activities
so you can see that when i tap
the dish
then
it'll it'll do this little tail flick to
see the neurons you would use a
different microscope that's a more
high-powered machine okay so you do this
and then you take it and then just image
deeper exactly okay
the scientists often use light patterns
to trick the fish into thinking that
they're swimming in a stream or running
into an obstacle
it's like fish vr
because the dots are changing which way
they go so the fish is going to be kind
of changing its pattern yeah exactly
fish is going to swim left right
this is brain activity that you see all
these
purple and orange dots these are
individual cell bodies and whenever they
flash that means these cells become
active
in a way florian's fish study is the
opposite of the connectome approach
rather than trying to untangle the whole
bowl of spaghetti
his lab can zero in on the specific
spots in the brain that light up in
response to stimuli
and then start to develop a theory of
what fishy thoughts look like
can you give me an example of those
lines like a zebrafish does x and i
could see that in the brain and find out
whether that's right so for example one
of the things we we are studying is
working memory so the fish sees a pulse
of motion yes sir and it remembers that
for a few seconds yes sir and now we've
identified a brain region where this
information this activity
is being stored in a recurrent circuit
so we can see by imaging by recording
activity that there is information in
this ventral hindbrain circuit of the
fish where this information stays so we
sort of have found now a nucleus for
working memory okay where this
information is being stored transiently
i think the
critical part is you need to know
already right how it works and then you
can use it to test many of my friends
and colleagues and they won't like what
i say now
so if you don't know how it works then
having the connectome is is going to
hurt you more than it's going to help
it's going to be much more confusing
than illuminating should we be spending
money to even try to do a human
connectome or
just even if just because we can or well
no so you know i think we should
absolutely it's about expectation
management we should not do the human
connect on the same we shouldn't have
done the genome for the purpose
of using it to directly cure disease or
help the human condition because that's
not going to work
but what it's useful for
is to help the existing science
infrastructure
to constrain the models right it's
another additional tool that will help
you
with incremental insight most of the
wealthiest people in the world these
days are tech people and they're
interested in stuff it seemed like well
we could do this and we could do it a
lot faster if we just had 50
high-powered microscopes and more brain
slices i'm surprised no really wealthy
person it's interesting where the brain
stacks up versus the body on some of the
priorities of research
it's not clear what you would do with it
i think maybe that's the problem if you
had a billionaire
and say i can give you a connect home i
mean her question would be
what am i going to do with that right
what you will will you do once you have
to connect home and i think one of the
most prevalent
applications which i think is
budget crazy is to upload yes sir oh do
i go towards your animation
that that is the substrate of your mind
that you can then actually upload it
into a computer and emulate your mind
there's a lot of also rich people who
are um after that and i think in
uploading of my brain it's more like
making um a backup copy right that is
disjointed from my own identity there's
really a philosophical flaw a a wrong
way of thinking that a copy is the same
as a continuation of my own um life so
that's why i think all of this is is is
complete nonsense i mean this idea of
the connectome as a tool to upload my
mind into a computer and and achieve
immortality
is
is crazy
after spending a couple of days talking
about brains i took a slow walk around
harvard to feel what ivy league life is
like
as i sauntered majestically
i thought about mark zuckerberg building
a dating site here
and then ending up as our digital
emperor
i thought about how weird it is that
we're totally dependent on google's huge
computers and algorithms to do so much
cutting edge research
and i thought about my director david
running with a roller blading brain
scientist
i thought about a lot of things and well
i reckon it would be nice if we knew how
that happens
you